[Musique]
une étoile d'or là-bas illumine le bleu
de la nuit derrière les monts la lune
blanchi la verte colline 1818 2018
il ya deux cents ans et c'est le poète
réunionnais leconte de lisle le conseil
départemental a décidé de célébrer le
bicentenaire
tout au long de cette année est de faire
vivre dans toute crise est à l'écouté
l'année leconte de lisle d'horizon du
bicentenaire de naissance en 200 ans ont
depuis sa naissance et se sont fait cet
autre chose il a lui-même écrit
énormément de de prose de poésie de
critiques littéraires des journalistes
également il laisse ses enfants
donc c'est passé beaucoup de choses là
clairement sur un col une école qui
était le leader
il a révolutionné la poésie de ses
contemporains
ces analyses
donc cette année sur rue essaye de
traverse à ses 200 ans à travers le
patrimoine écrit que nous conserverons
de département dans les collections des
archives par madame béatrice sigismeau
vice président délégué à la culture a
présenté le programme mis en place par
la collectivité dans le cadre de l'année
de leconte de lisle une année dédiée à
l'un des plus illustres poète de notre
île est enchanté de cette année année
leconte de lisle et on va travailler sur
ce projet avec tous les équipements
culturels que nous possédons à la
réunion mais le projet porté plus
particulièrement par la bibliothèque
départementale de la réunion qui est
basée à saint denis et qui a en sa
possession des oeuvres de leconte de
lisle et nous avons comme ça dans
différents lieux gardé d
des oeuvres authentiques domine le bleu
de la nuit d ailleurs les monts l'année
de planioles il serait peut être une
année pour découvrir la poésie de
l'auteur la redécouvrir la partager dans
les classes dans les médias et sur scène
[Musique]